Herr Bohrnemann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61.
61?
Im Wahnsinn sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 7. August 1963.
63.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,86 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie diese Zeit?
95 kg.
95.
Danke schön, Herr Bohrnemann.
Herr Bohrnemann, was für zu heute ist uns?
Ich habe ungefähr seit 3 Stunden sehr starke Kopfschmerzen.
Seit 3 Stunden?
Ja, seit 3 Stunden.
So starke Kopfschmerzen habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Zum ersten Mal haben Sie sehr spürtig so Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe schon mal Kopfschmerzen gehabt, aber nicht so stark.
Nicht so wie diese jetzt.
Aber diese Kopfschmerzen langsam oder plötzlich begonnen?
Und die haben relativ schnell bekommen.
Wo genau sind diese Kopfschmerzen?
Ganz in der Kopfschmerzen?
Ganz in der Kopfschmerzen.
Und das ist so drückend, als wenn der Kopf zerspringen will.
Ja, ich bin sehr stolz.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen mehr beschreiben?
Sind Sie pulsierend, bohren?
Ne, mehr so drückend.
Drückend dumpf.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skalaphone 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 sehr leicht und leicht sind die Schmerzen in der Schmerzen.
7 bis 8.
Frau Spengerman, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 67 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 6. März 1957.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie jetzt so seit?
Zur Zeit wiege ich 60 kg.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin noch 20.
Ach so, ganz jung.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12.9.2004.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 m und wie ich so 69 kg.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Schröder.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15. März 1982.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß
und 82 kg.
Wo wohnen Sie?
Wo ich wohne?
Ja.
Könnten Sie mir den Namen Ihres Hausarztes verraten?
Das ist der Herr Wolf, Dr. Wolf.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen, Herr Schmidt.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23.11.1900.
Wie lange wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Zu viel.
76 kg.
Ich habe über Weihnachten etwas zugenommen.
Ich verstehe.
Es gibt viele Kekse und so weiter.
76 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,75 m.
Frau Müller, wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Ich bin 76 Jahre alt.
Das ist die Frau Grasius.
Frau Baumgart, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 28.09.1959.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,56 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
84 kg.
Das freut mich.
Frau Stegermann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Wie lange sind Sie geboren?
Am 17.05.1900.
Am 17.05.1971.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
66 kg.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schluter?
Ich bin 59.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12.03.1966.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schluter?
1,80 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ich bin 70 kg.
Alles klar.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 12.03.1966.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 80 kg.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 70 kg.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 80 kg.
Wie viele haben Sie geboren?
Ich bin 76 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 70 kg.
eigentlich gar nicht so von mir. Ich habe immer wieder Verstopfungen und dann habe ich wieder
Durchfall und also, dass meine Verdauung mir solche Probleme macht, das kenne ich eigentlich nicht.
Und jetzt ist es eigentlich, seit ja, zunehmend, dass ich auch Bauchschmerzen habe und zwar tut
das so, um den Bauchennabel herum ist es ganz schmerzhaft und es krampft sich so alles
zusammen und was ganz schlimm ist, es tut richtig richtig stark weh, wenn ich Stuhlgang machen muss.
Ja, und wenn ich dann das hinter mir habe, dann bin ich wirklich schweißgebadet und geht es mir,
bin ich richtig richtig kao und ich kriege auch nicht mehr gut Luft und fühle mich total schlapp.
Wie alt sind Sie dann, Herr Schuude? Ich bin 66, ja, ich bin 58.
Und wann sind Sie jener geboren?
Ja, am 12.03.66.
Okay.
12.03.12.
19.06.
Okay, danke. Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie, Herr Schuude?
Ich bin 182, zumindest immer und ich wiege so um die 70 kg.
70 kg, okay.
Gut.
Haben Sie eine Allergie?
Eine Allergie?
Ja, also, was ich nicht vertragen habe, ich habe mal Paracetamol genommen,
habe ich so einen jungen Ausschlag bekommen, das soll ich also nicht mehr nehmen.
Haben Sie die Lebensmetallnünfertrientigkeiten?
Nein, ich kann nicht alles vertragen.
Laktur oder Milch oder keine?
Nein, nein, eigentlich habe ich da nichts vertragen.
Super, super. Was ist Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Ja, habe Sie Stress in der Arbeit?
Ja, natürlich habe ich Stress in der Arbeit, als Lehrer, das ist Siegfried.
Okay, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
50 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Wie bitte?
Am 14.04.1974.
14.04.1974.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 76 groß.
Wie sind Sie? Wie viel sind Sie?
Ja, so um die 85 kg.
Wie alt sind Sie?
60 Jahre alt.
60.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 3. September 1965.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Und wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ich bin ungefähr 1 Meter 75 groß und ich wiege ca. 90 kg.
20 kg.
1 Meter 75.
75. Okay.